Навпроти мене Наталія Каплан, двоюрідна сестра Олега Сенцова і журналістка.
Я нагадаю: Олег Сенцов - один з найвідоміших українських політв'язнів, режисер.
Він був засуджений до 20-ти років колонії суворого режиму
і зараз перебуває за Полярним колом у Росії.
Наталю, щиро дякую , що погодилися поговорити.
Двадцять два дні голодування в понеділок, сьогодні, коли ми з вами розмовляємо.
У середу, коли буде ефір - 24 дні голодування.
Олег Сенцов вимагає випустити всіх українських політв'язнів.
За різними даними їх понад п'ятдесят.
Деякі називають цифру більше шістдесяти чотирьох.
Як зараз себе почуває Олег Сенцов?
Ну, Олег Сенцов, звичайно, почуває себе, м'яко кажучи, не дуже.
Досі інформація надходить виключно від тюремних лікарів.
Олег на терапії підтримки, йому на день зараз колють літр глюкози і вітаміни Бе.
Це все. Тобто жодної їжі він не вживає, п'є лише теплу воду.
Що стосується стану Олега Сенцова, треба розуміти, що чотири роки таборів -
будемо відверто говорити: таборів - вони здоров'я дуже сильно вбивають.
Зараз він перебуває за Полярним колом у російській Арктиці.
Мешканець півдня. І клімат йому абсолютно не підходить.
Клімат дуже вологий, крім того, що холодний.
В одному з листів Олег писав, що у нього випадає волосся, кришаться зуби.
Це ще було до голодування?
Це було ще до голодування.
Плюс у Олега з дитинства проблеми з серцем і суглобами.
З суглобами, я знаю, що дуже сильно погіршилася ситуація в Арктиці через клімат.
Він перебуває під наглядом тюремних лікарів, так?
Так. Він перебуває під наглядом тюремних лікарів.
Поки ми не змогли домогтися, щоб до нього пустили когось ззовні.
Чому?
Усі питання до Російської Федерації, чому вони не допускають лікарів українських чи міжнародних.
Чи спілкується зараз Олег зі своїми найближчими родичами, з вами зокрема, з дітьми?
Спілкування зараз відбувається тільки через листування.
Олег відмовляється від побачень,
каже, що йому так простіше триматися і взагалі легше від цього нікому не буде.
Розповідав, що бачив інших ув'язнених після побачення з родинами,
як їм було важко, в яку депресію вони потім впадали після того, як поїхали родичі.
І каже, що приїжджати до нього не треба.
І все ж він таки погодився поговорити з Ксенією Собчак і з Людмилою Нарусовою.
Це був відеодзвінок. Чому він зробив виняток?
Звичайно, це не близькі для нього люди, і що вони потім вам розповіли?
Вони мені нічого не розповідали.
Ми на зв'язку так і не були відтоді.
Чому Олег на це пішов? Ну, я думаю, а чому б і ні?
Можливо, щось сподівався почути, якісь фрази.
І так, це не близькі люди, йому, звичайно, значно простіше з ними розмовляти.
Як ви вважаєте, все-таки Олег перебуває у місцях позбавлення волі
вже понад чотири роки, якщо не помиляюся.
Що стало останньою краплею, яка змусила його піти на цей насправді відчайдушний крок -
оголосити безстрокове голодування?
Я не думаю, що був прямо якийсь... якась остання крапля.
Але за чотири роки...
Тобто для вас це було несподіванкою?
Для мене так. Але він готувався, хоча потай від усіх, але він готувався.
Тобто це був продуманий крок. Що стало причиною?
Ну, треба розуміти, що за чотири роки нічого не зрушилося з мертвої точки.
Навпаки, політв'язнів дедалі більше, більше і більше українських.
Вони накопичуються, накопичуються і накопичуються.
Тобто, так, йому описують все, що відбувалося за ці чотири роки.
Щодо його імені також, як там боротьба йде і таке інше.
Але результат дуже плачевний. Вкрай плачевний.
І, вочевидь, він не знайшов іншого виходу, як ось так заявити.
До голодування він готувався близько двох місяців.
Тобто він відмовився від передач, відмовився купувати щось у крамниці тюремній.
І почав баланду ось цю тюремну поступово знижувати.
Однак його вимога - це не власне звільнення, а звільнення всіх українських політв'язнів.
Як ви думаєте, цю вимогу можна виконати?
Олег дійсно дуже сильно переживає за кожного і дуже радий, прямо невимовно, коли хтось виходить.
Він так радів, коли вийшла Надія Савченко.
Він дуже радів, коли вийшов Гена Афанасьєв.
Він дуже переживав, що, коли йшла боротьба за них, щоб Геннадія теж не забували.
Це факт. Чи можна виконати цю вимогу?
Я думаю, що на сто відсотків ні. На це потрібен час.
Якщо Олега Сенцова звільнять, він припинить голодування?
Я дуже сподіваюся, що так.
Що він знайде... у нього будуть вже інші методи боротьби тут.
Він може виступати, може активніше діяти.
Другого-третього червня по всьому світу пройшли акції на підтримку Олега Сенцова.
Наскільки я знаю, в сімдесяти восьми містах світу були ці акції.
Чому вийшло так мало людей?
Адже справа Олега Сенцова нині одна з найрезонансніших, про нього говорять у всьому світі.
Особливо це стосується Москви.
Там вийшло, мені здається, не більше двадцяти осіб.
І мені сказали, що і в Києві очікували,
що вийде набагато більше людей, ніж з'явилося на площі.
Насправді людей вийшло значно-значно більше, ніж за всі ці чотири роки виходило.
Що стосується Москви і Росії, то, відверто кажучи,
ми й не розраховували на якусь велику кількість людей там, це зрозуміло.
Нові політв'язні нам не потрібні, вже "ось так", вистачає вище даху.
Що стосується Києва, то там дійсно...
Тобто це страх?
Це страх, так. Це, знову ж таки, незнання. Там же лише Facebook був.
По телевізору це не показували, про цю акцію, природно, мало хто знав, мало хто зважився.
Щодо Києва, справді, було певне розчарування,
тому що в цей же період була хода, закликали українські церкви
вийти за традиційні сімейні цінності,
ось ці от "скрепи", ось це все, і туди пішли кілька тисяч людей.
Акція по Олегу Сенцову була на Майдані.
Вони йшли повз, йшли, йшли, йшли, йшли.
Тобто там люди виступають.
Один виступив, другий виступив, третій виступив, гасла покричали.
Вони все йдуть, ідуть, ідуть.
І, звичайно, на їхньому тлі, як сказала одна правозахисниця:
"Так, друзі, ми, звичайно, маргінали в цій країні.
Права людини тут набагато менше цінуються, ніж ненависть".
Ну, на підтримку Олега Сенцова ще виступає величезна кількість опозиційних політиків,
діячі культури, правозахисники, багато незалежних ЗМІ.
Це все, безумовно, транслюють.
Лія Ахеджакова, відома акторка, сказала, що необхідно широко це висвітлювати у ЗМІ.
І це справді може допомогти.
Наскільки, ви вважаєте, ефективний цей інструмент тиску на російську владу?
Громадська думка?
Хоча, звичайно, як ви сказали - це справа меншості.
Чи може це змінити настрої в російській владі зараз щодо справи Олега Сенцова?
Я думаю, тут трохи інший механізм має спрацювати.
Тобто реальні важелі тиску, щоб випустити Олега Сенцова, звичайно ж,
у руках політиків, причому міжнародних політиків, які вже знають якісь слабкі місця,
або що потрібно зробити, щоб витягти людину.
Треба розуміти, що вони цим, звісно, не займатимуться,
якщо не знатимуть, хто такий Олег Сенцов.
І тут саме підключається ось ця дуже важлива частина захисту Олега:
це ЗМІ, це суспільство, це акції.
Принаймні я знаю, що в Європі і в Штатах все-таки прислухаються до думки суспільства.
На відміну від Росії.
І всі ці петиції масові, я думаю, що вони здатні достукатися до міжнародних політиків,
які вже будуть робити якісь конкретні кроки.
Я ніби пам'ятаю, що коли звільняли Савченко,
цьому передував дзвінок Барака Обами Путіну.
Хто зараз повинен зателефонувати Путіну з європейських політиків
або з американських політиків?
Навряд чи це буде Трамп, хоча я не знаю.
Я вважаю, що Трамп... було б непогано отримати дзвінок від Трампа.
Макрон, на жаль, так, звертався, ну якось, загалом все зійшло нанівець.
Будемо прямо говорити.
І Меркель, можливо.
А чому зійшло нанівець, до речі?
Там якось так вийшло, що Путін на його тлі виглядав набагато впевненіше і так далі.
А можете розповісти, як це все сталося?
Я так розумію, Макрон приїхав на економічний форум у Санкт-Петербурзі.
Так.
До нього зверталася величезна кількість людей.
Були опубліковані статті, зокрема, в центральній газеті французькій Le Monde.
Чому Макрону не вдалося бути переконливим? Чи він не хотів бути переконливим?
Я не думаю, що не хотів, але щось явно пішло не так.
Тобто сказати, що Макрон проти звільнення Сенцова, не можна.
Звичайно, він - за.
Йому передали книгу Олега французькою мовою,
і взагалі-то він, так, підтверджував у розмовах, що буде за це боротися.
Чому вийшло так, як вийшло, мені сказати, звісно, складно.
Я не знайома ані з Путіним, ані з Макроном.
Але якось це виглядало, звичайно, так собі.
Сподіваємося ще дуже на Німеччину, на Меркель, зокрема, тому що вона "вхожа" до Путіна.
І вона саме могла б стати тим переговірником дуже важливим,
який допоміг би зрушити цю справу з мертвої точки.
Олег зараз засуджений за сфабрикованою справою.
Це абсолютно очевидно, його звинувачують в організації теракту.
Чи не здається вам, що у Володимира Путіна є особиста неприязнь до Олега Сенцова?
Я скажу зараз, чим вона викликана.
Я подивилася останнє слово Олега Сенцова, яке він виголосив на суді.
Це було 2015-го року у серпні, і він тоді назвав Путіна "кривавим карликом". Це цитата.
Подейкують, я не можу це стверджувати, що Путін дуже болісно сприймає,
коли його особисто так характеризують.
Так, ми теж розглядаємо цю версію.
Це цілком можливо, що це особиста неприязнь,
бо Олег - єдиний політв'язень, який прямо з клітки так стрибнув особисто на Путіна.
Тобто жоден інший політв'язень до цього, ні Надія Савченко...
Я такого не пам'ятаю, щоб ось відверто "кривавий карлик" його назвати за присутності купи ЗМІ тощо.
Це так розлетілося.
Може, хтось ще і говорив, але я такого не пригадую.
Плюс відверто побажати йому смерті, вірніше сказати, що я тебе переживу.
Так, можливо, це особиста неприязнь,
це ми теж не виключаємо, тому що фактично Росії він зараз навіщо?
Він був потрібен на самому початку, щоб показати, виправдати анексію Криму,
щоб показати, що ось тут є терористичне співтовариство "Правого сектора".
Все це показали ЗМІ тощо, все пояснили. А зараз  навіщо?
Що роблять українські політики, чи достатньо вони роблять для того,
щоб звільнити Олега Сенцова?
Мені складно сказати, що саме вони роблять і чи достатньо роблять,
проте я думаю, що, судячи з результату, ні.
А що потрібно робити українським політикам ось прямо зараз для того,
щоб збільшити шанси Олега Сенцова на звільнення?
У першу чергу, ми вже не перший рік домагаємося з іншими родичами політв'язнів,
щоб в Україні з'явився уповноважений у справах саме політв'язнів,
які перебувають в Росії, в Криму.
Такої людини досі немає.
Фактично немає якогось координаційного органу, який би займався лише політв'язнями.
Тобто так, є МЗС, яке щось робить, є Мін'юст, який щось робить.
Є кримська прокуратура, є інші органи, але вони щось роблять,
але, як пояснила одна знайома людина, шестерні крутяться, але механізм не їде,
бо вони не стикаються одна з одною. І це все сумно.
Є такий відомий український політик, кум Володимира Путіна,
Віктор Медведчук, який займається проблемою військовополонених.
За його посередництва торік
відбувся такий доволі масштабний обмін військовополоненими.
Чи зверталися ви до Віктора Медведчука
з проханням посприяти звільненню Олега Сенцова?
Намагалася, але на зв'язок він не вийшов.
І не тільки я намагалася, інші родичі інших політв'язнів теж намагалися:
на зв'язок він не виходить.
Якщо говорити про Медведчука, я не думаю,
що така фігура, як Олег Сенцов - це все ж у його компетенції.
Це не так. Ба більше, як показує досвід...
Але він же сприяв звільненню Надії Савченко, наскільки я знаю з преси.
Ну, в принципі, так. Однак тут інша ситуація.Треба розуміти, що...
Поясніть, в чому різниця, між ситуацією Савченко і ситуацією Олега Сенцова.
Ну, дивіться, після звільнення тих політв'язнів більше він нікого не витягнув.
І як показує досвід останніх звільнень - це кримські татари
Ільмі Умеров і Ахтем Чийгоз, в принципі можна обійтися і без нього,
досить грамотно вибудувавши стратегію, наприклад, підключити Туреччину, Ердогана.
І це працює. Медведчук, який...
Ну, так, він звільнив кілька людей, і що?
Відтоді схопили скільки? Він когось ще витягнув? Ні.
То може ми не будемо на нього сподіватися,
а будемо шукати якусь іншу фігуру, яка може це зробити.
А в Україні є така фігура?
Я впевнена, що вона є. І я впевнена, що вона навіть не публічна.
Питання - чому українська влада
не зацікавлена у створенні такого органу або хоча б ось цього уповноваженого. Це дуже дивно.
Поговорімо трохи про справу Олега Сенцова.
Він був засуджений, я нагадую, до 20 років.
2015-го року винесли обвинувальний вирок.
Які статті кримінального кодексу Росії йому закидають?
Зараз ось прямо за статтями, я не назву,
але це організація терористичного угруповання,
організація терактів, підготовка до терактів,
незаконний обіг зброї ... Ось, по-моєму, так.
На чому будувалася доказова база слідства?
Доказова база передусім будувалася
на свідченнях двох людей.
Це Геннадій Афанасьєв і Олексій Черній, які йшли по цій же справі ...
Вони сказали, що так, Олег був організатором усіх терактів на світі,
які збиралися скоїти в Криму.
Пізніше на суді Афанасьєв відмовився від своїх свідчень, заявивши, що вони
були дані під тортурами, і все. Однак суд це не зупинило.
Це все одно лягло в основу справи.
Чи знали до цього Черній і Афанасьєв Олега Сенцова?
Олег з Чернієм взагалі-взагалі не знайомий.
З Геннадієм Афанасьєвим вони знайомі дуже поверхово.
Треба розуміти, що в Криму протестна тусовка тоді була не така велика і,
звичайно, люди так чи інакше один одного знали.
Десь якось перетиналися на акціях. Щось таке.
Чому саме Олег Сенцов став ціллю російських спецслужб?
Це якийсь випадковий збіг обставин?
Олег там, звичайно, був на олівці, так скажемо,
тому що це людина, яка вивозила українських військових,
допомагав, коли там дали все-таки коридор,
щоб із заблокованих частин українські військові змогли виїхати.
Він організував цей виїзд, знайшов автобус, і все це зробив.
Звичайно ж, він потрапив під нагляд ФСБ.
А коли у квітні там з'явилася структура з боротьби із тероризмом,
я думаю, що там все дуже банально,
людям потрібно було бігом заробляти погони і так далі.
Ось вони у квітні з'явилися, і в травні вже
вони знайшли терористичне угруповання відповідно.
Нахапали просто дуже різних людей, дуже різних ідеологій,
і все це зліпили в "Правий сектор", все це показали - і все.
Я думаю, що вони просто не розраховували, що буде такий резонанс.
Чому Олега зробили організатором?
Тому що, якщо подивитися на інших фігурантів, так званих фігурантів справи,
то, звичайно, Олег виглядає на їхньому тлі дуже солідно. Набагато солідніше.
Він, по-перше, дорослий.
По-друге, у нього справді лідерські та організаторські здібності є.
І по-третє, звичайно ж, що він не здався під тортурами.
Тобто, коли його катували, він все одно відмовився давати свідчення проти себе, проти інших,
йому відразу сказали: "Тоді ти станеш організатором і отримаєш двадцять років".
Що загалом і сталося.
Я подивилася фільм "Процес. Російська держава проти Олега Сенцова",
і там йдеться побіжно про маловідомий факт.
У Олега Сенцова є рідна сестра, її звати Галина.
У неї є чоловік, який працює в ФСБ,
і син, я так розумію, теж працює в ФСБ.
І чоловік рідної сестри Олега Сенцова дав свідчення проти нього.
Який мотив був у нього?
Я думаю, вислужитися. Він же раніше працював в СБУ.
Після анексії різко перейшов у ФСБ, і треба було вислужитися.
Так він і проти мене там свідчення клепав кумедні.
Коли він дав ці свідчення?
Я думаю, що у 2014 році.
Це допомогло йому якось просунутися по службі?
Я не стежу за його долею, я не знаю.
Ви не підтримуєте жодних стосунків?
Ні. Але я думаю, що навряд чи. Тому що,
наскільки я знаю, колишнім сбушникам зараз там не дуже солодко, які так ось перебігли.
Вони все одно там стоять з позначкою "Схильний до зради Батьківщини".
Але чи звинувачував він його в тероризмі?
Ні, такого, щоб прямо в тероризмі, не було.
Він просто дав свідчення, що Олег - нібито погана людина,
і ось він так налаштований антиросійськи, і Путіна хотів убити. Отак-от.
А він таке казав?
Та розмова, яка відбувалася до анексії, взагалі з цим чоловіком…
Ми приїжджали з Олегом, це був 13-ий рік…
У чоловіка, певно, ім'я є, я просто не знаю.
Микола. Ми приїжджали, ми взагалі обговорювали стрибки з парашутом з ним.
Звідки він усе це взяв?
Ну, так, ми з Олегом говорили про політику завжди.
І тоді в Криму теж, але точно не при ньому.
Тобто я це чомусь чітко пам'ятаю, тому що ми заїхали до них
буквально хвилин на десять привітатися, те-се і поїхали далі з Олегом.
Тобто він обмовив Сенцова?
Я думаю, що так. Хоча може бути десь щось і чув,
тому що ми справді з Олегом політично загалом схожі в поглядах і,
напевно, десь щось обговорювали. Може, навіть хтось щось із них і чув.
Сестра жодного разу не намагалася спілкуватися з Сенцовим? Маю на увазі, рідна сестра.
Вони листувалися кілька разів.
Ба більше, вона допомагає і приглядає за його дітьми,
що дуже важливо, і дуже важливо, що вся ця ситуація на дітях не відбивається.
Тобто ніхто не говорить, що тато поганий, що тато - терорист. Навпаки, що...
Але її ж сім'я сприяла тому, щоб тата посадили.
Ну, як сприяла... Я думаю, там би і без них впоралися.
Навіщо він це зробив, звичайно, велике питання. Мені її навіть шкода.
Тому що з одного боку брат, з іншого боку - чоловік і син.
З Олегом вони по різні боки барикад.
Проте в неї єдина претензія до Олега: чому він не поїхав.
По різні боки барикад вони були завжди чи тільки відтоді, коли Крим був анексований Росією?
Саме так, ситуація з Кримом все це розділила.
Ви кілька років тому переїхали до Києва. З чим пов'язаний ваш переїзд?
Так, незабаром буде два роки, як я переїхала до Києва.
Просто в якийсь момент у Москві стало неможливо жити.
Ви переїхали з міркувань безпеки чи з міркувань того,
що вам було важко перебувати в тій атмосфері, яка зараз панує або панувала в Росії?
По-перше, так, передусім, через атмосферу,
тому що ось це ось стеження, прослуховування - це неприємно.
Однак це не страшно, ми навіть з гумором до цього ставилися.
Так, було неприємно, коли почали закривати мої особисті рахунки без пояснення причин.
Тобто якось життя стало більш складним.
Звичайно, добила більше атмосфера, коли друзі стали відвалюватися один за іншим,
з людьми стало просто неможливо спілкуватися.
Кожне спілкування просто як отрутою по шкірі, хоч на вулицю не виходь.
І все це, звісно, зіграло більше, ніж якась ФСБ.
Наталю, до анексії Криму, до тих драматичних подій, які ми спостерігали  у 2014 році,
ви були такою політично активною чи суспільно активною людиною?
Чи це з'явилося через анексію Криму і справу Олега Сенцова?
Ні, досі я, напевно, все-таки була спостерігачем.
Тобто мені було зрозуміло абсолютно чітко, що відбувається.
Однак якихось прямо активних-активних дій з мого боку все-таки не було.
Тобто через особисте?
Ну, так, виходить. До цього я була спостерігачем.
Я говорила з багатьма людьми щодо справи Олега Сенцова.
Звичайно, більшість людей, із якими я спілкувалася,
які прекрасно знайомі з деталями, вони розуміють, що вона сфабрикована.
Але не всі готові докладати зусилля, займатися, по суті, правозахисною діяльністю.
Що ви можете сказати цим людям? Чому вони повинні допомагати Олегу Сенцову
або іншим політв'язням?
Я не думаю, що прямо повинні... Однак тут взагалі залишатися байдужим,
якщо ти бачиш якесь свавілля, напевно, важко.
Хоча я можу їх зрозуміти, напевно, Це, мабуть, навіть не байдужість, але...
А в чому ви можете їх зрозуміти?
Ну, я ж сама була спостерігачем.
Я прекрасно бачила всю цю ситуацію в Росії, яка складалася.
І якщо я щось робила, то дуже точково. Тобто сюди гроші, може, перерахувати,
там щось комусь допомогти, але це не було ніби прямо сенсом життя.
Це було дуже точково все.
Я не можу звинувачувати цих людей за те, що вони нічого не роблять.
Це їхній вибір.
Але якщо вони раптом захочуть діяти більш активно - welcome,
ми завжди дуже раді, і дуже вдячні. Величезне спасибі всім, хто діє.
Ви, я так розумію, за ці кілька років в Москві не були жодного разу чи були?
Я була у березні торік, ой, цього року. Так, в березні.
Ми їздили в Лабитнангі саме фільм знімати, де сидить Олег,
і їздили через Москву, де я буквально два дні провела.
Це все. Ось за ці два роки це була єдина поїздка до Росії.
Скажіть, ви займаєтеся цією справою вже понад чотири роки.
Ви говорили про те, що це занадто довго тягнеться.
Багато людей просто не в змозі так довго поступально і наполегливо
займатися одним і тим самим.
Що для вас найскладніше ось у цій ситуації,
в тому, чим ви зараз активно займаєтеся, і в чому вбачаєте, як я розумію,
головний сенс свого життя?
Найскладніше - це, звичайно, вишукувати сили,
щоб ходити на зустрічі нескінченні. Пояснювати одне й те ж тисячу разів.
Усі ці кабінетні лабіринти. Взагалі байдужість більшості політиків,
які можуть покивати, "так-так-так, це все так сумно", і все.
Потім ти йдеш в наступні кабінети, все те ж саме. Це, мабуть, найважче зараз...
На самому початку найважчим було, звичайно,
розгойдати суспільство, якось пояснити їм, що "ну, люди, він не терорист".
Тим більше складно це було зробити під час атаки ЗМІ,
коли там весь ось цей галас був про спійману терористичну групу. Це найважче.
Як ви зараз переживаєте безстрокове голодування Олега Сенцова?
У мене взагалі емоції останнім часом відключені. Тобто їх немає.
Звичайно, важко, і довелося більше якось акумулювати сил.
Довелося на роботі піти в режим фрілансу,
тому що я просто не можу зараз щодня з'являтися на роботі фізично.
Найбільше я переживаю в даній ситуації навіть не за Олега, а за його маму.
Я знаю, як їй важко.
Я кілька годин просто збиралася з думками, як їй повідомити,
зателефонувати про голодування Олега.
Не хотіла, щоб вона дізналася про це зі ЗМІ.
Притримали інформацію для цього. Звичайно, ось їй найважче в цій ситуації.
Чи змінилося якось ставлення політиків і громадських діячів
до справи Олега Сенцова після того, як він почав голодування?
Так, почали ворушитися. Таке відчуття,
що почалася якась двіжуха, яку ми чекали дуже-дуже довго. Активна причому.
Якби навпроти вас сидів Володимир Путін, що б ви йому сказали для того, щоб звільнити Олега Сенцова?
Я це питаю, тому що я бачила, що до нього звертався Олександр Сокуров тощо.
Що б ви сказали Путіну? Як би ви його переконали?
До сумління, до почуттів я б точно звертатися не стала,
тому що це абсолютно марно, я думаю.
Я б йому сказала, ну ось, логічно подумай, що...
Добре, Олег зараз помре. Це що викличе?
Це викличе нову хвилю санкцій. Ми цього доб'ємося, повір.
Це викличе хвилю обурення.
Це, можливо, призведе до Чемпіонату світу з футболу,
якщо не призведе до зриву цього чемпіонату, то ми зробимо все,
щоб інших якихось спортивних розважальних заходів у Росії не допустити.
Повірте, ми зможемо.
Ось, ви подумайте, що краще: пожертвувати і відпустити цих людей на свободу
і показати себе там супергероєм-гуманістом.
Або все-таки піти на зло собі і, як кажуть,
назло бабусі відморожу вуха. Що краще? Якось так.
Наталю, щиро вам дякую.
Дякую вам.